British investigators are trying to
figure out what's sickened a former
Russian spy who's now fighting for his
life the former double agent Sergei
Street Paul was found unconscious Sunday
on a bench in southern England a woman
with him had also collapsed Russia says
it's ready to help the investigation in
Fast Elizabeth Palmer is near the scene
in Salisbury England with new details
Elizabeth good morning good morning
Sergei screen Paul is a Russian former
Army officer and the spy who moved to
Britain in 2010 and this morning he's
lying critically ill in the local
hospital in Salisbury having been
exposed to what so far is being called
an unknown substance the couple in this
security camera video is thought to be
screw pal and his daughter Yulia walking
towards Salisbury downtown on Sunday
roughly half an hour later they'd
collapsed on a bench
Jamie Payne found them and called the
police when she's on the floor her eyes
were just completely white there
whatever but just white and frothing at
the mouth and then the man went stiff
his arms don't even they're still
looking dead straight
for the past 36 hours police in hazmat
suits have been scouring the places
screech-owl had been including an
Italian restaurant what they find will
decide what happens next the critical
thing is to get to the bottom of what's
causes illnesses as quickly as possible
as you'd expect the specialist resources
that sit within counterterrorism network
that I coordinated across the country
and other partners are working with
wheelchair pleading action back in 2004
scrip al was arrested in Russia and
sentenced to prison for spying for
Britain but in 2010 he was released in a
prisoner exchange
in return for 10 Russian agents
operating in the US including the
infamous Anna Chapman scrape all settled
in Salisbury in this modest house where
he seems to have led a quiet life until
now this incident inevitably brings to
mind the 2006 murder of another Russian
intelligence officer Alexander
Litvinenko he was poisoned in London by
radioactive polonium in what British
intelligence believes was a Russian
state ordered execution the local police
have just said that a small number of
those who responded to the emergency
call and got the sergei paul's to the
hospital themselves had to seek medical
care later on the BBC says they suffered
from itchy eyes and wheezy breathing
Viana
interesting to hear that Russia has
offered to help the investigation
Elizabeth Palmer and Salisbury England
thank you